(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, a gente vai estudar algo que
é excepcional nos leilões excrediticiais, mas que você
pode encontrar aí nas análises que você estiver
fazendo para o imóvel que está indo nessa
modalidade de leilão.
O que é isso que é excepcional e
você pode encontrar?
Você pode encontrar uma penhora no imóvel que
está indo a leilão excrediticial, na matrícula do
imóvel que está indo a leilão excrediticial.
O que é uma penhora?
O objetivo aqui dessa aula não é estudar
a fundo o que é uma penhora e
as consequências de uma penhora, porque isso aí
a gente analisa no próximo módulo, no módulo
de leilões judiciais, porque em todo e qualquer
imóvel que está indo a leilão judicial, a
gente vai encontrar lá penhora ou várias penhoras
no mesmo imóvel.
O objetivo aqui, então, é só dar uma
explicação breve sobre o que é uma penhora
no ponto que interessa para a gente no
leilão excrediticial.
Então, a penhora é uma conscrição judicial que
indica que o imóvel vai servir para o
pagamento de uma dívida que está sendo cobrada
em um processo judicial.
Traduzindo isso aqui, vamos supor que eu estava
dirigindo com o meu carro e alguém foi
lá e bateu no meu carro, um outro
veículo bateu no meu carro.
Para que eu conserte o meu carro, eu
vou precisar ali de um valor e vamos
supor que essa pessoa que bateu no meu
carro, ela não se mostrou muito interessada em
pagar aquele conserto.
Então, eu fui lá, paguei aquele conserto e
agora eu quero cobrar aquela pessoa.
Afinal de contas, eu tive um dano, um
prejuízo financeiro por algo que não foi minha
culpa, já que essa pessoa bateu no meu
carro.
O que eu vou fazer para cobrar essa
pessoa?
Eu vou entrar com um processo judicial e
aí esse processo judicial vai correr, eu vou
mostrar lá os danos que eu tive, o
valor que eu paguei e vou pedir o
ressarcimento desse valor.
Vamos supor que essa pessoa que bateu no
meu carro não tem a quantia ali que
eu usei para consertar o meu carro.
Então, o processo vai correr, quando o processo
chega ao final, aquela pessoa vai ser condenada,
ela vai ter que me pagar aquele valor.
Se ela não tiver aquele valor em espécie,
a gente vai começar a buscar alguns bens
daquela pessoa para pagar aquela dívida.
E aí, nesses casos, o que acontece?
Um leilão judicial de um imóvel, porque essa
pessoa não tem dinheiro, mas tem um imóvel,
leva o imóvel a leilão, o imóvel vira
dinheiro e aí sim o credor daquele processo
pode receber o que ele tem direito.
Então, para isso que existe uma penhora, para
falar que o imóvel vai ser utilizado para
pagar uma dívida.
E aí, se a pessoa, de fato, o
imóvel for penhorado, ela continuar não pagando aquela
dívida, aí acontece um leilão judicial de um
imóvel.
Assunto do Model 3 que a gente vai
estudar a fundo.
Agora, vamos supor que nesse meu mesmo caso,
essa pessoa bateu no meu carro, eu fui
lá, cobrei no processo judicial, ela foi condenada
a pagar aquela quantia e não pagou.
Na hora que a gente foi buscar os
bens daquele devedor, a gente só encontrou um
imóvel e esse imóvel tem uma alienação fiduciária.
Como a gente está estudando ao longo desse
Módulo 2, quando existe uma alienação fiduciária, o
devedor transfere a propriedade do imóvel para o
credor como forma de garantia para o pagamento
da dívida.
Então, quando existe alienação fiduciária, tecnicamente, o imóvel
não é do devedor, o imóvel é do
credor, já que o próprio devedor transferiu a
propriedade para o credor para garantir o pagamento
daquela dívida.
Então, quando a gente fala de uma alienação
fiduciária, o devedor fiduciante ele não é proprietário
do imóvel enquanto existe aquela alienação fiduciária.
Mas esse devedor, ele tem direitos sobre esse
imóvel e quais são esses direitos?
Primeiro lugar, ele tem os direitos de aquisição
daquele imóvel, porque, afinal de contas, basta que
ele pague toda aquela quantia que ele pegou
emprestada, que ao final do pagamento correto, o
credor vai entregar uma carta de quitação para
ele, o imóvel deixa de ser do credor
e volta a ser do devedor fiduciante, que
vai ser o proprietário pleno daquele imóvel.
Então, primeiro lugar, direitos de aquisição, basta ele
pagar certinho aquela dívida que ele deixou o
imóvel garantindo, que ele vai voltar a ser
o proprietário daquele imóvel.
Em segundo lugar, ele tem direito à posse
daquele imóvel, porque na alienação fiduciária, como a
gente bem estudou, existe essa transferência de propriedade,
o devedor transfere a propriedade do imóvel para
o credor, que vai passar a ser o
proprietário daquele imóvel, até que a dívida seja
inteiramente paga.
Mas, enquanto essa dívida está ali pendente, quem
fica no imóvel, quem mora no imóvel, quem
pode alugar o imóvel, reformar o imóvel, é
o devedor fiduciante, ele fica na posse do
imóvel.
Então, na alienação fiduciária, a gente sempre tem
um desdobramento ali, o proprietário vai passar a
ser o credor, mas a posse, quem vai
ficar de fato com aquele imóvel, usando aquele
imóvel, é o devedor.
Então, o devedor, na pendência de uma alienação
fiduciária, ele tem dois direitos, direito de aquisição
e direito à posse daquele imóvel.
Quando a gente fala desses direitos, é inegável
falar que esses direitos do devedor fiduciante, esses
direitos, eles têm um valor econômico, porque vamos
pensar aqui, quando alguém vai lá e faz
uma dívida, entrega um imóvel com a garantia
de uma alienação fiduciária, a pessoa vem pagando
aquela dívida, o final da dívida está aqui,
ela vem pagando, vem pagando, vem pagando, até
que o momento ela pode chegar ali no
final da dívida, e se ela não chegar,
ela pode perder esse imóvel, que vai ser
levado a um leilão extrajudicial.
Mas, enquanto ela vem pagando, esse valor que
está para trás, o valor que de fato
ela já pagou, esse valor aí, ele tem
um valor econômico, você vai somar aquelas parcelas
que esse devedor já pagou, e é inegável
que a soma dessas parcelas que ele pagou,
correspondem a um valor econômico.
Então, a gente fala que esses direitos que
o devedor fiduciante tem, na pendência de uma
alienação fiduciária, eles têm um valor econômico, valor
econômico de tudo aquilo que o devedor de
fato já pagou, e essa posse que o
devedor fica exercendo ali durante a pendência da
alienação fiduciária, ela também teria um valor econômico.
Então, vamos voltar lá no exemplo que a
pessoa bateu no meu carro, eu processei, abri
um processo judicial, o juiz condenou aquela pessoa
que bateu no meu carro a ressarcir os
danos que ela me causou, e aí na
hora que a gente foi buscar ali bens,
a gente só encontrou um imóvel, e esse
imóvel tinha uma alienação fiduciária, então tecnicamente esse
imóvel não é da pessoa que me causou
danos, é do credor dessa pessoa, mas essa
pessoa que me causou danos, ela é a
devedora fiduciante daquela alienação fiduciária, e ela tem
direitos sobre aquele imóvel, direitos de aquisição e
direito à posse daquele imóvel, e isso aí
tem um valor econômico.
Se a gente não encontrar mais bem nenhum
dessa pessoa que me causou o dano, o
juiz ele pode penhorar os direitos dessa pessoa,
ele pode penhorar os direitos que o devedor
fiduciante tem numa alienação fiduciária, já que esses
direitos têm valor econômico, e já que a
pessoa me causou um dano, ela tem que
me pagar, então se ela tem o único
negócio que tem um valor econômico que poderia
ser usado para me pagar, cabe a penhora
disso que ela tem para me pagar, então
vai surgir a penhora sobre os direitos do
devedor, que é justamente a penhora sobre os
direitos de aquisição e da posse do imóvel
que têm um valor econômico e podem ser
utilizados para pagar a divra dessa pessoa que
só tem esse imóvel com uma alienação fiduciária
pendente.
Quando a gente fala dessa penhora dos direitos
do devedor, essa penhora pode gerar um leilão
judicial de direitos do imóvel, mas isso é
assunto de uma aula específica do módulo 3,
não é o que eu quero entrar aqui
nessa aula, o que eu quero entrar aqui
nessa aula é o seguinte, a gente já
sabe que para o banco levar o imóvel
a leilão, antes ele vai ter que consolidar
a propriedade em seu nome, o que significa?
Significa que de fato o banco vai ser
o proprietário daquele imóvel e a partir daquele
momento da consolidação da propriedade, ele deve realizar
obrigatoriamente o primeiro leilão, se não vender o
imóvel depois ele vai realizar o segundo leilão,
uma obrigatoriedade da lei como a gente já
estudou aqui em um momento anterior nesse módulo
2.
Quando o banco ele passa a, quando o
banco ele consolida a propriedade em seu nome,
ele vai ser de fato o proprietário do
imóvel.
Agora vamos supor que nesse imóvel que o
banco consolidou a propriedade porque o devedor fiduciário
deixou de pagar aquela dívida, que nesse imóvel
existisse uma penhora dos direitos do devedor fiduciário,
o que vai acontecer com essa penhora?
A partir do momento que o banco consolida
a propriedade em seu nome, o banco é
de fato o proprietário daquele imóvel.
Se o banco ficasse responsável por essas penhoras
dos direitos do devedor fiduciário que existiam naquela
matrícula, isso seria uma tremenda injustiça.
Vamos botar isso aqui no meu exemplo.
Então o cara foi lá, bateu no meu
carro, me causou um prejuízo, eu tive que
entrar com o processo.
O único bem que a gente achou naquele
processo foi o imóvel que tem uma alienação
fiduciária, mas esse devedor ele também deixou de
pagar a dívida que ele tinha com o
credor fiduciário.
E aí o credor fiduciário vai consolidar a
propriedade no nome dele.
A penhora significa indicar que aquele imóvel vai
pagar uma dívida.
Essa penhora não era por uma dívida do
credor, essa penhora era por uma dívida do
devedor fiduciante.
Quando o credor consolida a propriedade para realizar
o leilão excruidicial, ele passa a ser de
fato o proprietário daquele imóvel.
Se ele fosse responsável pelas dívidas das penhoras
que recaíram sobre os direitos do devedor fiduciante,
por pagar de fato aquela dívida, isso seria
uma tremenda injustiça, né?
Colocando aqui em algo mais claro, a pessoa
bateu no meu carro, a gente foi lá
e penhorou os direitos dele, que ele tinha
sobre aquele imóvel, mas ao mesmo tempo ele
não estava pagando aquele financiamento, o banco consolidou
a propriedade naquele imóvel.
O banco consolidou, existia a penhora antes da
consolidação na matrícula do imóvel.
Se o banco tivesse que pagar aquela penhora
para cancelar aquela penhora, o banco estaria se
dando mal duas vezes.
Primeiro, que ele não está tendo pagamento da
dívida que ele deveria receber e segundo, que
ele seria responsável por uma dívida que não
foi ele que fez.
Olha que tremenda injustiça isso seria, né?
O banco que ali de boa-fé emprestou
dinheiro para uma pessoa, lógico que em troca
de juros, seria responsabilizado duas vezes pelo não
pagamento da dívida e por ter que pagar
uma dívida que esse devedor fiduciante fez e
que não tem nada a ver com o
banco.
Isso seria uma tremenda injustiça, isso não pode
acontecer e a partir do momento que o
banco consolida a propriedade em seu nome, o
devedor fiduciante que até então tinha os direitos
lá de aquisição daquele imóvel, ele vai deixar
de ter os direitos de aquisição, porque afinal
de contas ele deixou de pagar e o
banco consolidou a propriedade justamente para levar aquele
imóvel a leilão.
Então a partir do momento que o banco
consolida a propriedade em seu nome, o devedor
fiduciante deixa de ter direitos de aquisição sobre
aquele imóvel e porque ele deixou de ter
direitos de aquisição sobre aquele imóvel, aquelas penhoras
que existiam naquela matrícula devem deixar de existir,
porque senão o banco ficaria responsável por uma
dívida que não foi ele que fez e
ele seria duplamente prejudicado pela existência daquela penhora.
Então com a consolidação da propriedade, o devedor
fiduciante deixa de ter direitos sobre o imóvel
e essas penhoras devem ser canceladas, essas penhoras
que já existiam lá por dívidas do devedor
que não tem absoluta relação com o imóvel
e com o credor fiduciário devem deixar de
existir naquela matrícula do imóvel, isso não significa
que o devedor vai deixar de ser cobrado.
Então vamos voltar aqui para o exemplo prático,
a pessoa bateu no meu carro, entrei com
o processo, penhoramos os direitos do devedor que
ele tinha sobre aquele imóvel, os direitos de
aquisição que ele tinha sobre aquele imóvel que
tinha um valor econômico.
Ele deixou de pagar também o financiamento e
o banco consolidou a propriedade em seu nome
para realizar o leilão excrujicial.
Quando o banco consolidou a propriedade, a pessoa
que bateu no meu carro não tem mais
direitos de aquisição sobre aquele imóvel e aquela
penhora que eu tinha, do prejuízo que ele
me causou em um acidente de trânsito, devem
deixar de existir, afinal de contas o banco
não tem nada a ver com ele ter
batido no meu carro, eu jamais poderia cobrar
aquilo ali do banco, isso seria uma tremenda
injustiça com o banco.
Agora, a penhora vai deixar de existir na
matrícula do imóvel, ou seja, aquele imóvel não
pode mais ser utilizado para pagar a minha
dívida, já que o imóvel é do banco
e o banco não tem relação com aquela
dívida.
Só que isso não me deixa de dar
o direito de cobrar aquele devedor ali pelo
prejuízo que ele me causou, como é que
eu vou cobrar?
Vou ter que me virar para achar outro
patrimônio daquele devedor, tentar achar mais algum dinheiro
dele, alguma coisa do tipo.
A minha dívida não deixou de existir, eu
que vou ter que cobrar de outra forma,
já que aquele imóvel não tem mais nenhuma
relação com aquele devedor fiduciante, aquele imóvel passou
a ser do banco a partir do momento
da consolidação da propriedade.
O que você deve ficar atento nesses casos?
A gente falou aqui que a penhora vai
ser cancelada, como a gente vai estudar no
módulo 3, toda vez que a gente precisa
cancelar uma penhora, a gente precisa da ordem
do juiz que determinou aquela penhora para cancelar
aquela mesma penhora.
E aí, quando existe essa penhora numa matrícula
de um imóvel que está indo a leilão
extrajudicial, o credor, o banco, ele não pode
ficar responsável por pagar aquela penhora.
E, muito menos, o arrematante pode ficar responsável
por pagar aquela penhora.
Só que vai ter uma outra responsabilidade, que
é pedir para cancelar aquela penhora.
E esse pedido seria chegar até o juiz
e falar olha, esse imóvel aqui que tinha
uma penhora dos direitos do devedor fiduciante, esse
devedor fiduciante, ele não tem mais direito sobre
esse imóvel.
O banco consolidou a propriedade, levou esse imóvel
aqui a leilão, aí ou o banco, que
vai fazer esse pedido, ou o arrematante que
vai fazer esse pedido, se for arrematante, o
arrematante vai falar.
O banco consolidou a propriedade, eu arrematei imóvel
em leilão, não tem absolutamente relação alguma com
aquela dívida daquele devedor que existia, nem conheço
o devedor, não posso ser responsabilizado por essa
dívida, então eu preciso que cancele essa penhora.
Então o que você precisa olhar nesses casos,
quando existir uma penhora do devedor fiduciante, dos
direitos do devedor fiduciante, no imóvel que está
indo a leilão excrediticial, você precisa ficar bem
atento no edital do leilão, para você observar
de quem vai ser a responsabilidade por cancelar
essas penhoras.
Tem edital do leilão que fala que a
responsabilidade vai ser do vendedor, ou seja, na
maioria dos casos, de um banco, e tem
edital de leilão que fala que a responsabilidade
vai ser do comprador, ou seja, do arrematante.
Se o edital do leilão colocar nesses casos,
que a responsabilidade vai ser do comprador, ou
seja, do arrematante, no caso, você que está
analisando aquele imóvel, eu recomendo que você não
participe desse leilão.
Por que eu recomendo isso?
Já que você não seria o responsável por
aquela dívida, você só teria que pedir ao
juiz para cancelar aquela penhora.
O leilão excrediticial, ele tem uma grande vantagem,
que é você fazer um acordo com quem
está ocupando aquele imóvel, para que a pessoa
desocupe aquele imóvel, e aí você não precisa
recorrer em momento algum ao Poder Judiciário, você
não vai precisar de uma ação de missão
na posse, você vai resolver isso tudo fora
da Justiça.
A partir do momento que você entra no
imóvel que tem uma penhora na matrícula, e
o edital passa a responsabilidade por cancelar essa
penhora para o arrematante, o arrematante vai precisar
entrar num processo judicial, que foi o processo
judicial onde o juiz determinou essa penhora, para
pedir que o juiz cancele essa penhora.
Isso vai ter um gasto, você vai precisar
de um advogado para peticionar nesse processo, isso
aí pode ser um gasto que não existe
na maioria dos imóveis em leilão excrediticial, já
que você encontrar uma penhora ali é exceção
para um leilão excrediticial.
Então, por isso que eu recomendo você ficar
de fora, porque vai te gerar um gasto
extra, você vai precisar de um advogado para
peticionar ali naquele processo, isso aí deixa de
ser interessante no leilão excrediticial, já que uma
das grandes vantagens do leilão excrediticial é você
fazer um acordo e não precisar recorrer à
justiça.
Agora, se você realmente quiser aquele imóvel, você
decidiu que você quer pagar esse custo para
um advogado peticionar e pedir a baixa dessa
penhora, tem um modelo que vai ficar aqui
disponível nessa aula, que seria você preencher os
seus dados e aí entregar a esse advogado
para que ele faça essa petição pedindo a
baixa dessa penhora.
Se o edital colocar que a responsabilidade vai
ser do vendedor, aí tudo bem, aí o
vendedor vai realmente baixar e vai te entregar
o imóvel livre dessa penhora.
E aí já seria um outro caso, já
seria algo que você conseguiria utilizar ainda o
benefício de talvez não precisar recorrer à justiça
nesse leilão excrediticial, já que o banco faria
esse trabalho e você continua com a possibilidade
de fazer um acordo para a desocupação desse
imóvel e não precisar da justiça em momento
algum.
Agora uma observação, quando o edital falar que
o banco, que o vendedor, vai ser responsável
por baixar essa penhora ou essas penhoras, se
existir mais de uma penhora nesse imóvel, existem
casos em que o edital coloca lá que
o banco, o vendedor, vai ser responsável por
baixar a penhora, mas que não existe um
prazo certo para que o banco faça isso.
Então se você realmente decidir que você quer
participar, porque está lá falando que o banco
vai cancelar essas penhoras e que você acha
que aquele leilão vale a pena, saiba que
se estiver lá que não tem um prazo
certo, o banco não vai te garantir um
prazo certo.
Isso aí pode atrapalhar o seu pós-leilão,
já que para registrar ali a escritura de
compra e venda de um leilão excrediticial ou
para registrar um contrato de financiamento, vai ter
que existir a baixa dessa penhora antes.
Se o banco não se comprometeu com nenhum
prazo, pode ser que isso demore um pouco,
isso aí atrapalha um pouco o seu pós
-leilão, mas aí fica a critério de vocês
analisar ali em cada caso.
O que eu realmente não recomendo é que
você não participe se o edital colocar que
a baixa da penhora vai ser a responsabilidade
do arrematante.
Mesmo que você não seja responsável por pagar
a dívida, porque você não poderia ser responsável
por uma dívida que foi o devedor que
fez, que não tinha relação alguma com aquele
imóvel, você não poderia ser responsável, mas isso
vai te gerar um ônus, um gasto extra,
que vai ser contratar um advogado para peticionar
pedindo a baixa dessa penhora.
Agora, muita atenção a uma exceção.
Qual é essa exceção?
Se essa penhora do devedor fiduciante, dos direitos
do devedor fiduciante, for oriunda da cobrança de
uma dívida de condomínio ou uma dívida de
IPTU, aí sim o arrematante pode ser responsável
por pagar essa dívida.
Como a gente já estudou em um leilão
excrediticial, no leilão excrediticial você sempre deve ficar
atento ao que o edital do leilão está
falando lá sobre dívidas de condomínio e dívidas
de IPTU.
Se o edital colocar que as dívidas que
existem de condomínio e IPTU serão de responsabilidade
do arrematante, você deve calcular isso aí na
sua viabilidade financeira.
Se o edital falar que as dívidas que
existem de condomínio e IPTU serão pagas pelo
vendedor até a data do leilão, aí tudo
bem, você vai receber o imóvel livre de
ônus.
Então a exceção seria penhora dos direitos do
devedor sobre dívidas de condomínio e dívidas de
IPTU e o edital falando que o arrematante
vai ser responsável pelo pagamento da dívida de
condomínio e dívida de IPTU.
Se juntar essas duas coisas, aí sim você
como arrematante vai ser responsável não só pela
baixa da penhora, como pelo pagamento do valor
daquela dívida que existe, assim como acontece no
leilão excrediticial de uma forma geral.
Se o edital colocar que a responsabilidade pelo
pagamento da dívida que existe vai ser do
arrematante, condomínio e IPTU, você já vai calcular
isso na sua viabilidade financeira.
Se por acaso você encontrar matrícula de imóvel
que tem penhoras do devedor funcionante, quem está
cobrando aquela dívida é o condomínio ou é
a prefeitura de onde aquele imóvel fica localizado,
e o edital colocar que a responsabilidade pela
dívida em aberto será do arrematante e também
pela baixa da penhora será do arrematante, você
vai ser, além de responsável pela baixa da
penhora, você vai ser responsável por, de fato,
pagar aquela dívida.
Então nunca deixe de considerar isso aí na
sua análise de viabilidade financeira.
E por que você vai ser responsável a
pagar por essa dívida de condomínio e IPTU
que pode existir naquele imóvel ali e que
pode ter gerado aquela penhora?
Porque dívidas de condomínio e IPTU são chamadas
de dívidas propterrem.
A gente vai estudar isso mais a fundo
no módulo 3, mas as dívidas propterrem são
aquelas dívidas que existem porque o próprio imóvel
existe.
Então são as dívidas que existem pela simples
existência do imóvel.
Então alguém tem que pagar condomínio todo mês
porque aquele apartamento existe.
Se aquele apartamento não existisse, não iria existir
essa dívida de condomínio.
Alguém tem que pagar IPTU todo ano porque
o imóvel existe.
Se não tivesse aquele imóvel, não iria existir
IPTU.
Então o conceito é simples assim.
A dívida propterrem é aquela dívida que existe
porque o imóvel existe.
E essa dívida propterrem tem uma característica muito
peculiar.
Ela tem uma característica que a gente fala
de uma forma mais informal, que ela adere
ao imóvel.
Então não importa quantas vezes aquele imóvel mudar
de titularidade, você vai ser responsável por dívidas
anteriores.
Então por isso que você sempre deve ficar
muito atento em um leilão de quem vai
ser a responsabilidade por pagar essas dívidas que
existem de condomínio e IPTU anteriores ao leilão
porque essas dívidas são dívidas propterrem e essas
dívidas podem acompanhar o bem.
Então sempre analise no edital de leilão quem
vai ser a responsabilidade primeiro pelo pagamento dessas
dívidas.
Isso você vai fazer em todo e qualquer
leilão na exclusão que você for participar.
Se o edital passar a responsabilidade para o
arrematante, você vai colocar isso na sua viabilidade
financeira e analisar se ainda assim é interessante
arrematar aquele imóvel.
Pode ser que seja.
Pode ser que o imóvel esteja indo a
leilão com grande desconto em relação ao valor
de mercado e ainda assim é interessante você
arrematar aquele imóvel mesmo assumindo essa dívida que
tem em aberto.
Pode ser que você decida que não, que
a dívida está alta e não vai compensar
o desconto que está sendo oferecido e aí
você decide ficar de fora.
Se existir uma penhora dos direitos do devedor
fiduciante de dívidas de condomínio e dívidas IPTU,
além de pagar a dívida se o edital
colocar essa responsabilidade para o arrematante, você vai
ter que peticionar no processo informando o pagamento
e pedindo a baixa dessas penhoras.
Isso aí também vai ter um ônus que
você vai precisar de um advogado que poderia
não existir esse ônus no leilão judicial se
você tivesse um acordo.
Muita atenção a essa exceção.
Fique sempre ligado às dívidas que existem do
imóvel IPTU e condomínio porque pode sobrar de
fato para o arrematante.
Outras dívidas que o devedor possa ter feito
que não tenham relação ali com dívidas do
imóvel como condomínio IPTU, aí não.
Aí a responsabilidade será somente pela baixa da
penhora.
Mas aí eu acho realmente que você deve
pensar e ficar de fora desse leilão porque
isso vai te gerar um ônus que poderia
não existir na maioria dos leilões prejudiciais, já
que é muito comum de fato a gente
realizar acordo para a desocupação do imóvel.